yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing wii traitor what does that mean
which is out usually ok so is trying
some some rare english set up here with
it already a three before interesting
okay i just play like normal more
centralizing with a little bit less
space i'm happy to trade okay okay let's
try it okay let's trade
here I was intending c5 maybe hmm just
taking like to take actually here with
Bishop takes I cannot move my knight
maybe see five in trying to do something
against this e4 pawn yeah so these are
taking this will be pawn I would like to
Queen to e5 also would be nice i can not
good here to beep on I did not see that
this is a problem that we pause okay I
have an idea not I don't know if it does
much I try to what why realize I'd
Soviet window when sometimes you know
what kind of happened like the Medusa
nation but taking this a bit strange and
yes souls in itself and switch that all
so here I was thinking while it's
probably slightly better my idea won't
say exactly what the what the engine is
giving me funny then was my idea takes
takes look ahead and then try bouquet
form so here who came for Bishop g5
ticks ticks Queenie father whose was my
life and I hope that I'm okay
[Music]
we have six and once bury him I did not
play that opening good at one good why
it was a little bit better and maybe I
should take I mean I didn't want to do
that but given given that the game was
also bad let that was probably the
better choice I can put the night only
five and lives in general this is not a
fantastic structure for black but I have
some business minor pieces traded so at
least I shouldn't be in big problems
experimental in the game and maybe I
should avoid c5 I wasn't sure I wanted
to do something against the pawns but
probably taking is good to avoid that
one sided position from the game like
this is not so bad yeah okay at the end
there was some kind of problems mostly
bore not quite sure what's what the
problem was ok guys thanks for watching